let's see what this baby can do okay I
gotta go thanks for taking care of her
dad she loves having you around it is
the bottom of the ball really hot you
mom ever tell your old papaw home on the
Grace and using the parks of all time
those days were different there weren't
so many rules
your mom would come for the summer even
back then she was the voice of reason
here's a lifeguard should be we can say
sing of water let God sort em out what's
our attendance today down about 45% what
I suppose you've probably heard you got
some competition in town they got roller
coasters and a chairlift that actually
works this is our home can't just like
somebody taken what this place needs is
an excitement enema we're gonna make
this place fast and loose every ride
every attraction no rules
just pure [ __ ] that sounds kind of
dangerous let's see what this baby can
do
the new point is now
[Music]
wedi cymryd Udi's Levasseur like a
petting zoo hold my beer
[Applause]
[Music]
not as younger I could do for these it
[Music]
[Music]
you